you know everybody I was out of town
this weekend but everybody here in the
comedy universe is thinking about Brody
Stephens who passed away and the news
articles were everywhere I'm sure you
saw him all over the internet and you
know Brody uh you know Brody was a
one-of-a-kind performer and people say
that a lot but Brody kind of you know he
loved like knowing where people were
from and being able to relate to people
especially people from California um he
was he was a friendly guy he was a big
but he wasn't but he was he was gentle
he was really gentle fella and yeah and
it's just you know it's heartbreaking
it's heartbreaking and I've been
thinking about it a little bit and
called a couple people that had spoken
to him last and talked to him this week
and you know we've been talking about
how he was off his medication he was
struggling or he'd gone off and was
getting back on and that seems to be
what most people are attributing his
uncomfort to you know his the depth of
his uncomfort that had got to a point
where where he took his own life and
where he took his own life by you know
even hanging himself and and I mean it's
just scared I mean it's very sad you
know it's heartbreaking to know that
this humaneness you know this big entity
I mean he was six four maybe he was you
know he was loud and he was he was just
he was so alive on stage you know he
used to pitch baseball at Arizona State
he liked to play the drums he would drum
on anything sometimes during his sets if
the sets weren't going good he would
just get drum sticks or even invisible
drum sticks and to start playing on the
chairs in the stage or whatever you know
he
he you know just like any comedian he
loved the attention you know he loved
the you know what there was some
equation in the getting attention from a
stage that made him feel okay you know
it made him feel okay and um and it's
just wild it's like you you think like
oh well the medicine and my Mac you know
do are you angry at the medicine but
then the medicine may have been what
kept him comfortable for many years he'd
had an instance years ago where he went
off his medication and and it didn't he
had to be 5150 I think and I'm
paraphrasing here right you know he went
to a city you know he went into a kind
of a psychosis bit but you know I didn't
know Brody super well I mean I would see
him at the store we would talk nothing
real outlandish you know but he was
always you know nothing real nothing of
a ton of depth unless we were in a
conversation together as a you know with
other people
or unless specifically I was talking to
him about baseball or vitamins he'd love
to talk about vitamins and and different
things he did to make himself feel
better you know one thing that I noticed
in looking and thinking about him and
looking back at at watching him perform
he always talked about positive energy
he'd say positive energy and I always
thought I was like man it's so wild that
that's his his Creed it was kind of the
banner that he carried it was he just he
had to tech he had to tell us all like
you know we have to be forward you know
onward he was a definition of onward it
was constantly like you know lifting
spirits that was his thing and and now
I'll kind of maybe you know realize or
I'll wonder if maybe he was also just
really lifting his own
you know he always talked about the
positive energy because he needed to
lift his own spirits and uh you know you
wonder like you watch someone's act on
stage and you wonder how much of it is
real and how much of it is you know it's
like what's for the audience and what's
for the what's for the the Entertainer
themselves and part of the thing I think
in looking back at Bertie and this is
just my perception I could be wrong and
if this matter if I'm wrong or right but
that he was you know he was entertaining
the crowd but at the same time he was
lifting himself up like Heaney you know
all the times he talked about relating
to people like he would he would ask
somebody where they played you know
where they went to high school and
they'd say I went to high school it you
know at Reseda middle and then he'd
rattle off the address of the Reseda
middle I know where that is that's it
blah blah blah blah blah blah Antioch
Boulevard or something and then he would
say relatable like he had related to the
person in the audience and I guess now
I'm just kind of dissecting you know
some of this the way and so I guess it
was like you know he used these moments
on stage to to preach the things that he
needed for himself it seemed like or to
not preach them but to kind of speak
them the best way he could that he
needed he needed to feel related to and
he needed to have positive energy
constantly to keep himself motivated and
excited
and that that's how he did it that he
facilitated that they're getting on the
stage a lot and it's just some you know
it's just interesting it's interesting
how many times I sit there and watch
somebody's act and I'm like oh this is
an act but then how many times am I
think you know what in here are the the
actual the tools or the the exponents
that this entertainer is using to
actually keep themselves okay today you
know to keep themselves well mentally
well and then I thought Brody huh you
know Brody hung himself and that's just
so you know it's so crazy it's so
foreign it's so alien to think someone
standing on top of something you know
putting a rope around there's just so
many physical moments you have to go
through to do that and now if you're a
short guy it's probably not that you
know it's easy how you could hang
yourself off of a you know off of a
handle on a shipper robe probably if you
had a but a bit of big tall man you know
and then he was a 300 you know Brody was
probably 250 he was thick he had the
brownness over here you know he was
brontosaurus he had them big bones you
know I mean you'll see you might see his
bones on the Flintstones he had those
kind of bones
then thick hitters baby them you know he
had that real that dude was marrow
plentiful he had a puppy he probably had
about two pounds of marrow in him
straight marrow
and you think about somebody going
through those motions and I'm sorry to
talk about some of this but you know I
think I need to think about it and uh
and then I'm not sorry to talk about it
because this is you know this is what
this is but it makes me sad at me you
know the first thing you think is like
could I have done something else and you
know it's uh yeah I hate to say this but
I felt I feel like his death maybe was
unpreventable and I never thought about
this before whenever someone that I knew
had taken their life or but Brody got a
lot of he got it you know he got a lot
of attention at The Comedy Store on
performing he had friends that he was
close to that you know they talked about
mental health he talked about mental
health a lot like that's another thing
if I was switching doses or something
excuse me you know I take you know I
take antidepressants I take you know I
don't know what - sertraline or whatever
I think it selects and politic one of
those and I'm switching to something
else called vibrant but but he talked a
lot you could talk to him about that you
know and he would tell you kind of what
his experience had been if he had taken
it something of that or taking something
similar or just you know he would always
you know he seemed like a lifeguard a
little bit on the edge of the pool of
mental wellness and if you were in the
pool you know he wasn't like that
lifeguard that was over there with the
glasses on and the whistle was trying to
[ __ ] everybody you know and see eating
out with a little sunscreen here and
there you know in saying they're going
to get a soda but really they're going
out to their car to get a little hit of
weed and come back in there and then
they're supposed to save people when
they're high on weed like people in my
hometown used to I remember going a
lifeguard one time doing a friend of
mine
I think he's drowning lifeguard was like
man I'm [ __ ] up brother and that was
it it's hard to go and try to rescue my
friend man and thank God I was able to
help you know when an old man helped her
I thought honestly in hindsight pdf-file
man not even because he kept helping him
like he helped him out of the pool then
he helped him back in the locker woman
whose towel and my buddy do my buddy
wood what the [ __ ] going on out here
but but anyway you know he was like that
lifeguard that was on the pool of mental
well on the edge of the pool of mental
wellness and he could help you he was
there to talk to you if he needed to and
he was a caring guy he had a big heart
and I think if there's anything that I
you know we all think person you know we
relate to the world personally so if
there's anything that I feel remorse for
my own in my own little life it is that
I didn't get to know the big heart that
was inside of him better you know that I
didn't make more of an effort and I
never knew sometimes it Brody was being
serious or not you know I never knew I
never knew if he was being serious or
not a lot of times but I bet if I'd have
spent maybe a little more time getting
to know him that I would have known more
but I mean that can be said for anyone
in your life goes the way it goes and
you can't know everybody but it
definitely seemed like I haven't heard
anyone say oh there were all these
warning signs there was the fact that he
was changing medication or gone off his
medication was getting back on his
medication and that you know apparently
there was there's a pretty big dip
sometimes when that happens in your you
know serotonin levels or I don't know
you know I'm going out on you know every
day John every day Jackson rhetoric here
but her every day Jackson diet right you
know I'm just talking out of my butt but
also with some of my brain in there but
that he went off on those that he went
off and he got back on and there was a
dip in there and then
and then that's you know whenever he
found some you know maybe a level of
discomfort hit him and and his brain
wasn't at a level where it could handle
it or something uh you know I don't know
we'll never really know we'll never
really know so you know and it's crazy
to think if it's unpreventable I mean
it'd have been preventable if he didn't
switch his medications maybe but there
wasn't it didn't seem like anything
anybody could have said that day or did
that day you can't spend every night
with someone that you don't you know you
know we can't you know people can only
really do what they're doing and do the
best that they are doing in a specific
instance and you know and the hanging
part is what also gets me out you know
with Robin Williams hung himself it's
such a and I don't mean this in a base
way but I mean this in a it's such a
performer thing you know it's such a
like a display you know it's like it's
like a last it's like your last bit it's
like oh I need to show you that I'm not
doing well and I couldn't show anyone
how bad I'm feeling or how uncomfortable
I feel except with this last display of
art
because it's such a presentation you
know it's such a specific thing it's
like I need to stop my head like I need
to I need to like litigate my head from
my body and that's not called ligature a
ligature yeah I need to stop I need to
stop this head from infecting the rest
of me and this is the only way I know
how to do it is to literally or not
literally but you know I don't know just
to cut it off at the past I need to
tighten right here so that my brain
doesn't keep bothering the rest of me
and I didn't mean to get on it you know
it's just sad man it's very sad and and
people say suicide is selfish and yeah I
think I think suicide is a selfish
saying maybe yeah it's you it's your
life it's your relation with the world
but I just don't know how this would
have been preventable you know unless
his medication you know maybe he didn't
or if he wasn't I'm not sure if a doctor
recommended that he switched with his
medication and get off and get back on
or I don't know man
it
sad though it's sad to think that there
was this this being that's just not here
now but I do hope that he's a somewhere
where he is at a lot more at peace and
I'm sure that he is it's heartbreaking
you know one of the saddest things I
feel like or one thing that I feel like
is sad and I don't know if this is judge
middle and somebody but Brody did a
great job of you know the Comedy Store
has like there's a lot of comics a lot
of the same comics work there you know
it's just like a lot of comics that are
doing well right now and those change
over time and and you know Brody always
had like kind of a later night spots so
he always was kind of like the king of
this sort of later night group of
comedians in a way that were sort of
that are a great comedian but just
aren't in the top like four or five
spots and I'm kinda I'm out there sort
of in the middle of those groups which
I'm grateful to be in and that's their
judgement of me
and that's I don't I'm happy to be at
the Comedy Store I am it's the only
place in LA that I really feel
comfortable and uh
and Brody was kind of right yeah like
into these sort of late-night spots
where he kind of held down he was kind
of like the king of this little
late-night kind of crew and uh you know
and I just know they're all gonna miss
their you know their fearless leader
that had all this experience
you
you know but rest in peace but you know
we love you and I'm sorry that we didn't
tell you that more